ça fait plaisir de revoir de nouveau de
la vie sur le campus quoi des rencontres
des échanges des sourires et le brouhaha
des couloirs plusieurs signes du retour
à une vie étudiante quasi normal c'est
aussi la reprise d'activité du tissu
associatif de l'université versailles
saint quentin exemple avec l'association
icare spécialisé sur les questions
écologiques elle propose des activités
autour de jardins partagés de paniers
légumes bio ou encore une recyclerie de
vélo on va réparer nous nos anciens
vélos mais également on va en acheter et
revendre ensuite aux étudiants pour
promouvoir une mobilité
verte plus verte une quarantaine
d'associations sont proposés aux
étudiants de l'ue vs qu une atmosphère
joviale ressentie jusqu'à
l'administration de l'université je
trouve que les étudiants sont très
chaleureux et je pense qu'ils sont
vraiment contents de ré échanger avec
nous comme nous on peut l'être avec eux
c'est vraiment au risque qui m'a le plus
frappé oui plutôt on sent un apaisement
et une
joie d'être ensemble en cette rentrée
2021 c'est aussi le retour des cours en
amphithéâtre
c'est le cas de ces étudiants en master
un parcours évolutions technologiques
organisationnelles et stratégiques un
plaisir général conflit près d'une
personne
il ya plus une connexion qui se passe
influent et derrière nos écrans ça
c'était pas possible parce que une fois
du cours se terminent et ben on
éteignait nos ordinateurs et puis voilà
en présentiel nous sommes en
apprentissage à les
actifs donc on apprend plus efficacement
d'afro mieux contrairement à ce que l'on
faisait avant l'essentiel c'était de
l'apprentissage passif d'une manière
générale ils sont contents de se
retrouver
de l'état nouveau en cour d'état nouveau
ensemble on les sent plus active plus
aller coûte durant le premier semestre
ses élèves ont 20 heures de cours
magistral en présentiel sur le
management